Kim Kardashian released her new book of  selfies entitled selfish that's right  that's the cover of the book  now it's sold so well they're now coming  out with a book on tape version yeah and  apparently it was recorded by our own  Andy Richter Andy I didn't realize you  did this you always seem down on outside  bucks all right well we have some video  of that recording session for Kim's book  let's take a look okay Andy you wanna  pick it up on page 12  sure Oh butt cleavage a but again this  time a little shinier but but boobs but  oh actually that last butt was boobs yes  please  but  [Applause]  we got if you're in the car if you're on  long hard trip yeah yeah it took you six  months to record that it certainly did I  like to get things right  okay the consummate perfectionist wasn't  that a great clip subscribe to my  youtube channel for an endless supply of  me  [Laughter]